Mark Halperin and John Heilemann New
York joining us now the former mayor of
New York City Rudy Giuliani much in the
news in the last few hours because of
remarks he made on Wednesday night here
in New York at a dinner for Republican
Governor of Wisconsin Scott Walker mr.
mayor I want to ask you very
specifically about the the line you said
about the president that's gotten so
much attention you said about the
president that he doesn't love America
he said I do not believe that the
president loves America
is that what you meant to say is that
what you think that's the impression I
get from what he says yes that he
doesn't have a deep abiding love for
this country the way other presidents do
that he seeks to criticize it more than
AB listed and doesn't get the notion of
American exceptionalism Haslem and I
felt that for a long time and honestly
what you just said I probably have said
50 of the times in slightly different
ways some of which has actually been
covered but never got quite got this
amount of attention the one that
probably put me off over the top is when
he described American exceptionalism as
being no different than Greek
exceptionalism failing to recognize that
Greece never never emancipated slaves
and how you can compare American
exceptionalism to any other country to
me it's very hard to believe
well mr. Mehra presumably Greeks loves
our country too and the president has
said stated many times he loves this
country so I'm curious why you can't
take that notion at face value either
the president and you disagree on a lot
of things but that he's still sincere in
his professed love for the country I I
am I want to take him at his word that
he's a sincere in his professed beliefs
but I think his beliefs indicate that he
is basically critic of the country and I
think his whole background and
development kind of made him that way
but the background I'm referring to is
the association with Frank Marshall
Davis the association with the Salwa
Winsky group which essentially seeks the
overthrow of the power structures in our
government and through peaceful means
I'm talking about the fact that he very
often
overseas we'll find ways to criticize
America sitting in Reverend Wright's
church - 17 years after a Reverend
Wright said not god Bless America but
god damn America I think even if I
wasn't in the pew that day I quit that
church so I don't I don't get from I
don't I don't personally and this is my
interpretation and opinion I don't get
from the president that same sense that
he has that deep abiding almost romantic
love of America that I used to see in
Ronald Reagan him and and and Bill
Clinton I see him more as a guy a
patriot but from the point of view of
wanting to criticize us and improve us
and I think he'd do a better job if he
did it with a lot more positive
reinforcement mr. mayor the White House
commented today on your comments that
they read the full quote which was I do
not believe and I know this is a
horrible thing to say but I do not
believe the president loves America
that's what you're quoted is saying the
White House one of the spokesmen there
today said that he agrees with you that
that is in fact a horrible statement to
make about Obama do you have anything to
say to the White House and their
criticisms of you they actually do
remember that you've said similar things
back in your presidential run in 2008
you have anything to say to the White
House yeah I have to say it's horrible
to say and it's too bad that I have to
say it'd be a lot better if I could say
that I had a president that I was
convinced had a great and abiding
understanding of America's
exceptionalism that we I had a president
who could stand up to his Islamic
terrorism and call it for what it is
that I had an American president who
didn't get confused about the Crusades I
wonder I wonder how much he understands
the Western civilization to be talking
about the Crusades I mean somebody
should be worrying about the president
not me I have no authority but somebody
should be worrying about the president
and his thinking when he's talking about
the Crusades
when Islamic terrorists recruit people
using the Crusades as a device for
recruiting and he's talking about the
Crusades as this it was a one-sided
thing in which the Christians were
brutal
I remember the history of the Crusades
it was fairly equal brutality on both
sides and by the way it was 800
to a thousand years ago so I think the
White House should get the president
kind of focused on the world we live in
and some day say the words Islamic
extremist terrorism I also wonder how we
can have a battle for the minds and
hearts of the Islamic world if we don't
discuss it if we don't discuss what's
wrong with the Islamic world if we don't
discuss how how the Koran has been
misinterpreted how it's been misused and
in some cases not misinterpreted in some
cases some of the things they're doing
are in fact based on the Koran to have
that discussion you have to have the
courage to say that there is such a
movement as Islamic extremist terrorism
and you can't deal in the silly
ambiguous euphemisms that the president
is dealing with and I think that's all
part of the same picture policy
differences with the president I think
the word that people are really focused
on is the word love and I don't wanna
have like a full platonic this notion
about what do you mean when you say the
president doesn't love America what does
that mean to you well actually if I
could express it more clearly what I
mean is he doesn't express it it I
should say
does the president does it does not love
anything or anyone I don't know I don't
not a psychiatrist and he doesn't have
one and he doesn't need one so you're
saying when you listen to him the words
you hear make you think that he doesn't
express the way that would give you the
confidence that he loves America but you
got it but you don't doubt but you don't
doubt that he loves America right if you
want to put it that way
I don't doubt that he loves America in
the sense that he's a patriot he
believes in the Constitution he's going
to follow the laws of the United States
I just don't know how far I don't know I
don't know that I don't know that it
really loves America I could be
persuaded if he would talk like that but
from the way he talks it sounds to me
like a guy who has trouble expressing
love for America that's different than
what you said it and and we're not here
and I sort of trap you or to play a word
game but but you're saying it
differently now you're saying he doesn't
talk like someone who does her he
doesn't talk to me that gives you the
sense he does but well that's still but
but guys that's generally I can
interpret him no I have when I say he
doesn't love America
all I can base that on are the things
I've heard him said I don't know I don't
know deep down in his heart if he loves
America or or he does it when I listen
when I listen to him I do not hear the
same things that I've heard from other
American presidents about American
exceptionalism about what a great
country it is about how how lucky he is
to be wit to be where he is
given where he came from just like how
lucky I am to be where I am given where
I came from I don't hear I don't hear
those things from you can you can
interpret you can understand the why
given that you just said you're not a
psychiatrist and you don't really know
what's in the president's heart you
don't really know what this is in the
president's mind you could understand
why some people would find the notion of
you saying so boldly I do not believe
that the president loves America is
needlessly provocative right you
understand why people would would say
that seems a that's that seems to be
imbuing yourself with with mind-reading
powers that you just admitted you don't
actually know I think it's my opinion I
think III I don't claim any special
powers I have no special powers of
analysis I have no special degree in
psychiatry or psyche or psychology
that's my opinion my opinions from
listening to him is that he doesn't
exude the same love of America that
other American presidents do perfect
right I have a perfect right to that
opinion all I ever hear from them is
criticism of America including outside
the United States which truly offends me
at a couple of the comments that he's
made including the most recent one about
the Crusades just about knocking me out
of my chair do you think it's possible
for someone to be critical of the United
States of its policies of its actions in
history and still love the country
absolutely but then I want to hear him
spending a lot of time talking about
that but that love of the country and
where it comes from and other American
presidents have been very critical of
the United States
but it's always been presses by so
a statement that what it's a great
detail about what a great country this
is and how this is a country that can
correct itself and a country that's done
great things and a country that's done
exceptional things and thank God you
know thank God that we were born here
and the God allowed us to be born here
those are the things that I think I'm
missing from his rhetoric that leads me
to the conclusion that there's a problem
in that area it's not as if I have or am
claiming and I do not know him I don't
have any special insight into him this
is all from an outsider who is viewing
what he says and the way he act okay mr.
mayor former New York City Mayor Rudy
Giuliani thanks for making time to come
on and clarify a bit with us appreciate
it
thank you thank you guys it was very
fair interview I appreciate it thank you